rich good morning what was the big topic
scuttlebutt prior to the draft obviously
it was how unpredictable it was going to
be and how even the first overall pick
had some uncertainty surrounding it and
then what would happen with the second
overall pick and that could have gone in
many different directions but the
direction it went was something that
nobody talked about which was the Bears
trading at one spot from three to take a
quarterback because when we were all
looking for landing spots for true
Biscay war or Watson and we're looking
at the Niners at two or Jacksonville as
the sleeper at four in case you know Tom
Coughlin comes in with the fresh set of
eyes and thinks that Blake bortles is
into guy of the future and they haven't
picked up his 50-year option yet maybe
that was the spot certainly the Titans
at five were looking to trade out and
that was a spot in front of the Jets
where everybody thought that a
quarterback could go even whispers that
the LA Chargers might be in the hunt for
Phillip Rivers eventual replacement and
then all of a sudden the team to take a
quarterback first as the Bears in it's
Mitchell true Biscay that was definitely
something nobody saw coming but if it's
the guy they want I I guess the big
concern I have is who were they
negotiating against it was San Francisco
can you lie in those situations is that
what why I haven't been on the air last
night I said I said did San Francisco
find out from Chicago who they wanted
before before they said yes to the trade
and all three guys is that Mayock and EJ
and who you haven't come up and and
David Shaw all said absolutely and you
know David Shaw has been in draft rooms
with the Ravens with Daniel Jeremiah
actually back in the day and Ian
Rapoport reported that the the Niners
didn't ask who that was that this is a
value trade for them as a matter of fact
they used that time later in the ninth
picks they got from the Bears to pop up
from the second round to come back in
and take Rueben Foster so they use the
exact of the value right away but you
know who knows really and did
really matter I guess in the long run
and you're right if the Bears love this
guy and they think he is the next
quarterback of the future and can
actually perform better at the position
than Jay Cutler did over the last eight
years and even though they just signed
Mike Glennon and are going to give him a
shot at it I mean if they think that
you're Biscay can do that although
clearly that won't be this year with his
13 career starts under his belt and then
more power to him but I I think that
that definitely still shocked a bunch of
people but you look what the Giants gave
up to get Eli Manning you give up
Phillip Rivers you gave up a third-round
pick a first-round pick a fifth round
pick we didn't know exactly what Eli
Manning was going to be they eventually
won a couple of Super Bowls but if you
look back that's a whole lot that you
gave up for Eli Manning now his pedigree
is you know front and center and more of
a sure thing than Mitchell true Biscay
but I'm all for the team that's all in
to get their guy that's the guy but you
have to have talent around you and I
know the Browns are being patient here
rich but they didn't try to make up for
the mistake they made last year with
Carson Wentz was that a good strategy or
bad strategy well I was asking that all
last night you know especially since I
mean think about it can you believe this
that they owned the Texas first and
second round picks next year because the
second round pick in that Sixers you
know trust the process right it's great
that they did with with with brown Rock
connections together for Brock gospel I
got a second and a quarterback which
rarely happens and now they got the
first four for deshaun Watson they had a
shot at once last year past Suns on it
to get a first-round pick that they
could have had Watson with this year
passed up on it and I guess they just
don't don't like those those guys and
then the same way that the Sixers here
in this town are eventually going to
have to win with the guys they draft
they're actually going to have to start
playing basketball games they intend to
win and start getting enough steam to
win games the Browns will have to do
that now
I still love Myles Garrett you obviously
know how I feel about your Pro Peppers
and that David and Joker kid came on my
show about a month ago and he is just a
mountainous smart bright-eyed 20 year
old please really young so they're
amassing talent at some point they will
have to get the triggerman and perhaps
Davis Webb is that guy I'm hearing a lot
of people love Nate Peterman josh dobbs
is terrific
could be Deshawn Kaiser I don't know
could be those guys were they'll go in
with Osweiler and Cody Kessler and with
those two first rounders and three
second rounders they have next year
darn 'old and we're expecting Josh Rosen
to come out there's a bunch of kids that
that are next year's draft that if they
do want to still be patient they can go
get but you also look at these other
teams that reached a little bit Kansas
City really wanted Patrick mahomes and
he's not going to play this year and
Houston really wanted to Shaun Watson
he won't start this year but he'll
probably end up starting by the end of
the year I mean they they gave up a
whole lot too I know that the Bears are
going to be criticized here but Houston
and Kansas City especially Kansas City
you know that's a team that can win now
you're opening up against New England
and you use your first-round pick you
trade up you give up picks to get
Patrick mahomes yeah and it was
incredible again that that was the first
time in the common draft era that three
quarterbacks went in the first round and
all of them were required by teams that
that traded up to go get him yeah and
the one with mahomes was surprising
because everybody thought that deshaun
Watson was similar in style to Donovan
McNabb and we all know how well Reed and
McNabb did in that offense for years and
they went ahead and got the Favre type
guy in Patrick mahomes and which you
know Reed would know very well how to
coach or do his best to try and coach
from back in the Packers days but you
know it is there that the Chiefs are I
don't want to call them ready-made to
make a Super Bowl run because I thought
they were last year and we saw what
happened so that though Alex Smith
they've got and I wouldn't I wouldn't
count against Shawn watson starting I
mean think about it last year
last year carson wentz and we talked
about last night true Biscay hi just 13
career starts under his belt once had 23
that's it and when he was drafted last
year 23 starts under his belt oh well
he's third on the depth chart and he
wound up starting from week one and was
terrific so I wouldn't be surprised if
Dashon Watson can pick things up quickly
in the Bill O'Brien offense and they
just say let's go let's go and
interestingly enough if that happens in
week six the Browns come in and just
like last year and the brown started
their first game last year of a huge
action era against whence they might see
the kid that they passed up and have to
play them he's Rich Eisen for the NFL
Network they got coverage of rounds two
and three coming up tonight garyun
Conley reportedly took a lie-detector
test for the Baltimore Ravens
you know III is this unprecedented it is
it's a bad look I mean this is the way
the way to put it but it but then again
it's tough for me to say that because if
the kid didn't do it then then you know
I have no idea I have no idea and the
Raiders I think deep down nobody they
don't know either and they decided let's
give it a whirl I mean all I know is
that you know the guy who's going to be
in whose room he's going to be in is one
of the finest people I've ever met in
Rod Woodson and so if and rod was the
one who taught me the phrase uh you know
if you want to soar with the Eagles
don't who with the Owls which is what
Chuck Noll always told him about never
never going out and about and so if he
needs to have his head screwed on any
tighter rod will be the one to do it and
because he's now the official full-on
defensive backs coach in Oakland so I
honestly don't know what to make it
other than the fact that right now with
him under investigation for this and
he's a first round pick 24th overall
just a bad it's it's it looks bad what
makes me on mad talking about Tim Tebow
but he also got mad last night rich when
the Commissioner was taken too long to
get up to the podium and that's Philly
man and I think he used the word
freaking about five times last night too
and he's in his element I mean there's a
hundred thousand people on the Benjamin
Franklin Parkway for crying out loud
we're Draft in Philadelphia you
his hometown and and he lives for this I
mean you know John Lynch said it at a
press conference this week when asked
about what what he looks at for you know
in mock drafts that are placed in front
of him and he mentioned Mayock is having
the best and because every place that he
went you know at a pro day he looked up
and he saw Mayock there too and I
mentioned that to Mike and you know he
kind of rolled his eyes a little bit but
he because he doesn't want to toot his
own horn I'll do that for him he's the
best I mean for somebody who's got a
host to draft like I you know I'm I'm
doing to have him at the end of the set
and now you know the guys coming up next
on your show Daniel Jeremiah is very
special to and and Charles Davis is
coming tonight to his David Shaw it was
just a first round analyst for us it's
great now it's there's nobody like him
he's the best what was the game plan if
it rained last night if it rained last
night it for us you know there's like
one of those shower curtains that you
could pull around and it was because
when we practice first on Tuesday it was
raining and it was brutal if it happened
last night
look the end it would have been it would
have been given brutal look the NFL got
lucky with the first you know cold
weather Super Bowl quote-unquote degrees
that day and it had a snow storm of epic
nor'easter proportions the next day that
mess with a lot of people's travels
plans but they got lucky and supposed to
be really nice tonight and a little
cloudy but no rain Saturday and it was
in again I got to tell you it was
unbelievable scene last night yeah
Pauling in my lemon window is that right
yes open so with the I didn't I didn't
see them there so that means the glove
it had a there are a hundred thousand
people no no lemon had a good connection
to Wi-Fi and 3G when he was trying to
act smarter than everybody else by
tweeting out that is what happened
McLovin yeah what what is your saying it
says everything that people don't know
because they're watching the television
part of draft that's you're messing with
my livelihood would you do that
the glove and were you telling us the
glove an answer rich I have a bad
connection here is a what a good time I
had getting a free dinner with Chris law
oh yeah all those people in our industry
Dan who don't have to be tethered to the
NFL because they're not quote unquote
partners with them that can go on
Twitter and act so smart because they
know the information before everybody
else does love and get them it's just
the ultimate threat to the televising of
the draft that's it the number of people
that say oh gosh you're acting like
you're you're not tipping pics I'm off
of Twitter I don't I don't sit on it you
know nor does the ESPN
but any rate nobody new in time time is
silly though nobody knew you didn't know
a pic last night before no no no in the
mothers here had made a children's head
dan and and three Wingo did not have
that either well I mean I can't speak to
him but he tells me that that's the case
and I believe it I really do believe it
yes but I know for a fact we do not know
they do not tell us they don't even say
in our ears this is a big one get ready
Mayock and i and everybody who's on that
set and anybody's been on that set we
don't want to know because we want to be
just as shocked as you at home what is
the point what is the point and and I
understand it's against it Dan it's a
21st century and this is a 20th century
operation where where a pic is made
somewhere it's called into a desk in a
different town where somebody writes it
down and hand delivers it to somebody I
mean we could do this like a fantasy
draft and be over in three and a half
hours if we wanted but it's a television
show for a reason for three days to drum
up interest in the and have a fun time
and what a spectacle it was last night
so well good luck tonight well thank you
good luck with your encore performance
coming up tonight that's tonight and
then all day Saturday up to mr.
irrelevant Thank You bud that's Rich
Eisen host of the NFL Network the
original show an audience Channel 239
from noon til 3:00 Eastern
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience